hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome to
the very first episode of the churno
podcast
uh something i've never done before um
something i'm very scared about
i i have no production team behind me
i'm going to be doing all of this stuff
here so if the
audio levels are rubbish you guys have
to let me know
but um i'm very excited to start this
new podcast thing it's something i
wanted to do for a really long time and
uh i think it'll be um it'll be cool to
kind of talk to
you guys in a live format as well about
various topics relating to like
programming game engine development
you know whatever it is that's going on
and hopefully we can have some really
interesting guests on this show as well
because i do plan to
hopefully try and include guests in
pretty much every single episode
so this episode is actually uh sponsored
by pbs
studios so for those of you who have
heard of pbs studio
will know that it's quite a quite a nice
piece of software to have with you as
you're developing your own software
um pbs studio is a static analyzer and
what a static analyzer is is basically
like a little friend
to help you when you're programming so
it's kind of like a spell check
for like your your word document or
whatever but it's for your like c
plus plus code or java they support a
few languages um
there you can check out pbs studio by
going to the link which is here
and if you're watching this on youtube
there'll be a bunch of other links in
description they also have a facebook
page and stuff like that
but um i recommend you guys hop on that
if you use the uh code hash
churner in the message field you'll also
be able to get yourself
a free trial and try out the static
analyzer for yourself and that's
actually a pretty decent um
segue i think into the guest that we
have today because our guest
is none other than yuri from pbs studio
so why don't you say hello yeah what was
i saying oh yes right
uh thank you for bringing me here
uh because i'm watching you on youtube
for like i've been watching you for like
a year probably
maybe more not regularly because
you know who watches youtube these days
regularly but
um yeah but i stumbled upon your channel
when i
was trying to figure out how to make a
game engine
it was a passion of mine and it still
kind of
is it's just on pause right now because
um i i've got
a ton of development and related things
at work and sometimes when i go home i
just want to
you know take a break from it
okay so that's pretty cool i didn't know
you were into game engines actually that
didn't come up in any of our
previous conversations that yeah very
relevant it was my dream to
become a game developer a while ago cool
a while ago so that's faded
no it's it's on hold on pause okay now i
i still of course i would like to get
into the game industry
one day but where i live
is difficult to do and
i would either have to move or do a
remote job to do
some of the cool stuff you know
uh well so i'm still
thinking about it but right now i've got
this
thing going with the static analyzer
which is basically
a compiler out under the hood
it's not the entire compiler but it's
still interesting
um it's the front end part which
actually deals with the language itself
and
it process uh type information syntax
and stuff like that
yeah i think it's probably worth talking
a little bit about because i think um
maybe you said that in the first kind of
section but we we missed that now
um that uh so yeah you work at pvs
studio as a software engineer and you're
working mostly on like the you were
saying like the front-end compiler
stuff maybe just talk a little bit about
what it is that you do at pvs studio
um i'm doing the core module for
the c plus analyzer and uh
well we have several of them we have c
plus plus we have c sharp and we have
java
and i'm in the biggest one
which is c plus plus um so what i
usually do
i well fix bugs mostly because
because it's a big old project obviously
um
and recently we've started doing
some uh refactorings uh
changing big parts of our uh tool
and i was a part of it i actually
implemented a new type system for the
uh for the analyzer because we need to
understand types
of variables and whatnot well also i'm
doing diagnostic rules which is
an interesting um thing itself
especially when you have to go fix
something in the core
uh because you come across some
either missing functionality or a bug
when you are doing
um some diagnostic rules for the
analyzer right
cool so that's pretty interesting um
c plus c sharp and java so
okay so here's a question for you um
since you were saying that the the code
base is pretty old how often do you guys
run pbs studio on the pbs studio code
base
oh that's that's a platinum question
come on everyone asks
yeah every every night
uh in our ci
it runs on the entire code system and
before we
uh commit some uh any changes to the
uh repository uh we also test locally
we run dvs studio on pbs studio and see
if it finds
anything funny
uh yeah and if you if you don't do it uh
during the day
after you made some changes uh you come
to the office uh in the morning and you
get
a nice little message
which says you screwed up uh here's what
you
here's what you did you should be
ashamed of yourself
so it's an automated spam email
which which sends you
all the new warnings the analyzer was
able to find on your code that's you
wrote
so it's kind of embarrassing yeah no it
sounds similar to like continuous
integration that we had back when i
worked at ea which was just like
um you know any any time the build was
broken it would email
everyone the whole team and it would be
like this is the person
this is the person who broke the build
this is their commit
and it would even it would even print
like all the errors from the compiler
and then usually we had something uh
that would basically we had tvs like
hanging around
like our kind of development area and
then it would just like the scrolling
text like html
like marquee would just like scroll
across being like
cherno and then like red and then like
ships syncing and all that stuff so yeah
good times it's always good
it's always good to blame people oh my
goodness
our guys from the management will
probably be
watching this um so better not give them
funny ideas
that might take some of those ideas
no well actually it's it's funny because
it is a bit of a joke but to be honest
i feel like um after that happened to me
a few times
i definitely like paid more attention to
my
commits because um i had this thing
where
i would just forget to commit a file and
i mean i still do this with hazel and
people yell at me but um i would commit
i would just
you know just forget to commit a file
and obviously that would break the build
and everything
so i remember i would always double
check um all of my
uh all of my builds after that all of my
commits
yeah i i think you learn that fast
when especially when something bad
happens
like a crashed build uh and smoke
everywhere
and usually we have our team lead um
out in so if you if you go enter the
office and hear ah
bill is broken again what
you know what happened usually
um yeah so so i think that like um since
we have you here today
um i think it would be uh because i did
mention this is supposed to be like a
bit of a programming kind of development
podcast
and i mean it's you know we'll see where
this goes um
but ultimately like i thought a good
topic for today's podcast would be
um how to write good c plus plus code so
in other words in all of your experience
and i'm very interested to hear about
um your opinion on this uh you know
because i deal with a lot of c plus boss
code i deal with a lot of questions from
people being like how
do i learn c plus plus how do i become
better at c plus plus like what even
constitutes good c plus plus code how do
i know that i'm writing good c plus plus
code
and since you work at pbs studio um and
you have for
a couple years now and um you know you
obviously deal with
software that is supposed to find
problems with people's code i think
there's a lot that we can kind of talk
about there
um and hopefully give some advice as
well to all of our listeners
um as to so maybe how they can improve
no matter what level they're at and
what kind of some of the problems you
see often are
something just fell anyway continue
alright so i guess
i'll start from from far away because
um just how i got into this thing
uh programming um
i had yeah that i had that's a good
start we can start from the beginning
yeah i had pascal at school
and we had a very good teacher uh so i
loved it
but i didn't have a computer because um
i grew up in russia in 90s and it was
you know interesting times
in terms of what happens in the country
and in terms of
what kinds of computers are available
so i didn't have it and
at some point i learned about this funny
language called
c and i thought sounds interesting
let me check it so i had a book uh
on c and c plus and i learned it
using the book because i i couldn't even
try it
at first and then i got a computer
i began just you know
trying things out uh testing this uh
trying that and then i got my first job
um not really related to programming
then
that's not an interesting part then i
got a different job
kind of related to programming and now
i'm at pvs
um what i mostly did
um like with programming in with
c plus plus i did my teeny tiny you know
pet projects
and that's where i once i decided to
okay i'm writing a game engine i want to
be a game engine developer
i don't really know how it works but
okay
the internet will help me uh i will i
will manage
uh so i made a kind of a bit of
monstrosity which is under
a rug now because i need to
exit big time yeah and
a couple couple of different projects i
had a game um
when i was um going on the
interview at pbs i decided to
you know refresh myself in terms of
coding and
write something big so i wrote uh
what was it it was a space invaders
clone
and a cockroach simulator you know a
little thing was running around on the
map
uh finding food dying of hunger and and
stuff like that
that sounds cool yeah um
and that's kind of my story in short
so i'm i've learned most things in
practice
i had some programming at the university
but it didn't really help
so i guess the first thing to become a
good programmer
a surprise you have to write a lot of
code
that's what i always say yeah i i
i think that's inevitable because you
really have to
go up there and write and it's it's like
if you ask a writer how to be a good
writer
what first advice uh you would have
right right go and write write a lot
um yeah and um regarding
you know small things um
i think it's all about um actually about
readability
so you need to write your code in a way
that reads like a sentence
i shouldn't you shouldn't stumble when
you
when you go through the code you should
be able to
read it smoothly if if you can't read it
smoothly enough
maybe you should do something with it
well as an example um let's say
you have a condition somewhere in your
function and it says
if this and that and
that and also this or
something right it's impossible to
read usually because it will be
your check uh your condition will be
like bloated with
details and uninteresting stuff
so in this case uh
what i'm getting to is put
blocks of code which are difficult to
read in functions
so decompose it make it
make it modular and
if you noticed i've i haven't said
anything about
the code itself yet just about the
structure
so i i think that the structure the way
you structure your code is
more important than your
i don't know knowledge of some fancy
constructions or something like that
if your code is well structured
it will be it will be good even um even
if you write your
your algorithm in a bad way
an efficient who cares honestly
you can rewrite it later but to rewrite
it later you have to
read it uh you have to be able to
understand what's going on there
um who said that there was an advice
from
someone uh from some big guy
who said write your code
in a way write your code
as if the person who who will read it
is a paranoid maniac who knows where you
live something like that
yeah yeah i've had that one yeah so
i guess that's the uh the first
and the most important thing
uh and about uh small things uh
what what i found beneficial really
is believe it or not uh to use auto
hmm a lot
i think the only type when i declare
variable
the only type i write explicitly is bull
i don't know why because i don't know
four letters maybe or maybe bull is so
insignificant of a type so
and there's a good reason for that
actually
because i mentioned refactoring uh which
we
were doing and i can tell you uh i can
tell a little bit about that
yeah so if it's fine yes if i don't yeah
before you do that i just wanted to
mention a few things um
yeah like i totally agree with what you
were saying um i think that
uh yeah there's so many so many things
here to talk about but you pretty much
said them so i'm not gonna repeat them
but um yeah basically the first of all
again it's it's almost surprising to me
the amount of people who actually talk
about
or ask me um or ask anyone really you
know how do i improve
um and the thing is uh i guess i was
kind of the same as well when i was
younger and i'm not sure if this is just
young people i presume it's not but
um the way that you improve at really
anything in life
the way that you improve at anything in
life really is by practicing and by
spending time at that thing
right i mean um for most things
in life time spent the more time you
spend on something it's directly related
to your skill level at that particular
task
right programming is no different um and
i think that it's it's kind of because
programming is so technical i think that
it's very easy for a lot of people to
get caught up in the theory and reading
like textbooks or thinking
uh you know that was rubbish i'll try
and get this other book and then maybe
that will help me better
but um i always compare this to like
learning to play a musical instrument
like if you're trying to play guitar and
i think i read somewhere online that you
do play guitar don't you
um um i kinda do
um i'm not good at it
um i i can play like a couple of songs
by pink floyd and
felt solos before you ask nice
um yeah and a couple more so it's it's
my skill there is probably basically
i'm trying to improve but um yeah you
just can't
do everything in life but i i certainly
don't know a recipe how to do everything
[Music]
yeah of course when you have 24 hours a
day so
no it's no time it's very there's very
little time the older i get the more i
realize how little time there is i think
but um yeah but like to do with with
that like i think that um
you know if you were learning learning a
musical instrument like it doesn't
matter how many
books you read or how many videos you
watch on youtube you're not going to be
able to just
you know after a hundred hours or
thousand hours of theory pick up a
guitar and just play
you know because you don't have the
actual like muscle skills or
any kind of like um any idea of really
what to do unless you jump into it
practically and i think the programming
is very much the same way
if you just kind of uh read all these
books and
read code even without actually writing
it and trying things for yourself and
failing repeatedly and you know um
not overthinking things but you know
what you said about performance as well
is like who cares if it doesn't perform
very well i
i still fall into the trap of just
sitting there being like no i shouldn't
i shouldn't ride it this way like that
that would be bad but then in a month i
might be like okay
life is too short i'm just going to make
this work and then if it's a big problem
i'll solve it later because my my goal
usually when i'm programming is to
create something it's not to just
um you know programming itself is not a
puzzle i'm trying to solve
in in in some cases it might be but
usually there's a product on the other
end of that
code you know the code is supposed to
create something and then at the end of
the day if it creates
the thing that it's supposed to create
um that's my goal
not to solve the problem in as fancy
a way as possible and i think that
that's something that a lot of people
fall into as well
yeah but at least read scott myers
i think his books are great on modern c
plus plus because
uh he has pretty good information
and um oh my god what
i was going to say um
oh yeah about um
that uh writing a product
uh and not uh solving a puzzle um
programming wise i think you should aim
for
that mvp uh concept you know
a minimum viable product yep so if you
have that
if it works that you're good basically
you can improve it you can build upon it
but
you don't have to do it like perfectly
it should work uh the first thing it
should work and it should be somewhat
finished
so it should do things
which are logically complete yep yep
yeah i think that like the whole mvp
thing is definitely something i've been
doing in my hazel engine because um at
the end of the day i think that like
it's
it's interesting coming from ea working
on like frostbite and
other engines to working by myself
mostly with a few
uh amazing contributors as well from the
community but still mostly by myself
like it really puts into perspective how
little resources that is to build
something as complicated as a game
engine and so mvp i feel like is almost
my middle name because
um at ea i would have spent way more
time on this tiny feature
you know like a month on like this just
tiny thing but you know with
my engine it's like no i have to move on
from this
i can't spend a month on this because
that's all the work that is sometimes
going to happen
on the engine it might be that so i
can't spend like a month designing a ui
panel and
trying to like hook it up so it's really
cool um that's not going to happen so
yeah mvp i think is really important for
a lot of people probably watching this
because a lot of you are probably
working on small projects maybe and you
have you're not working in a large team
at an organization yet you're still
learning so just keep that in mind like
small steps try and try and kind of
finish an entire slice
of a feature first and then maybe return
and fill in all the blanks and the
details later
if you have the time to do that yes and
another advantage to doing things this
way
is if you have a big project ahead of
you it will be
overwhelming it's guaranteed especially
if you're alone
uh but if you can see progress like oh
cool
this little thing works uh oh cool i can
test it um
and see what it does oh by the way one
thing i heard and i kind of agree
is when you are making something
the first thing you should do is to put
something on screen
like as soon as you see uh something on
screen
which your program produces uh it gives
you motivation it kind of makes things
not that hard in perspective so
it's a psychological thing but uh for me
it works
yeah if you just if you're sitting there
writing a library or something
and you don't see how it works it it
becomes
it becomes boring you become
afraid of not finishing it stuff like
that so
yeah not something on screen yeah no
definitely and that's
i think maybe like i'm that's why i like
rendering so much and i think that
graphics programming is great because
um at least in my mind that's like
that's one of the
well again in my opinion one of the
coolest things you can do with code is
actually create something visual on the
screen out of nothing basically
um and like that's really good it's even
cooler if you're not using like you know
graphics api for your gpu but you're
actually like rasterizing everything
yourself and your own software renderer
that's where i started programming um
but um
because that's even cooler because it's
like every pixel everything you're doing
is just an
array of numbers which you're
manipulating and yet they make an image
um and i think that's yeah that's
definitely super cool
yeah the first time i tried to show
something
like i i don't even remember what was i
i think it was my space invaders clone
i used uh windows api and i
just created a window myself and used
the gdi to render everything
and put sprites there on screen so and
then i saw it
and i was like well it's rubbish but
it's cool
i made it it worked yeah
great yeah no definitely um
oh man i just i remember that that
passion i kind of had for programming
i mean i still kind of do but i think
that um
uh you know it was kind of more magical
in the beginning for me because i wasn't
i didn't understand how anything worked
and it really was like magic
um but now i'm sitting here like as an
adult
being like well you know there's more to
life than programming first of all
and also why is this why is it so
difficult to draw this triangle or why
is it so difficult to do this and it's
like i feel like it's it's
it's more like um it's almost like it's
turned into work now obviously which is
what it has been for me for a long time
but
back when i was uh in high school and i
was teaching myself
um you know programming because i wanted
to
render graphics on my own without using
a 3d program
like for offline rendering um that that
was really cool when
when i was kind of learning that and
trying to actually put pixels on the
screen
and succeeding um yeah yeah
when you just uh when just begin is like
oh pointer what is it my goodness i will
never
learn that and um well actually i
started with java
so no point is there yeah
references everything is a reference
uh yes and when you uh when you're doing
it
for like several years it's like uh
this new feature what uh concepts uh
it's not it's not that convenient i
would have liked uh but okay
so it's it yeah
as you get more experience magic kind of
goes away it washes away uh from what
you're doing
yeah uh but still interesting so
i guess don't discourage anyone
no that's not no i think that um
it's yeah like i still get super excited
when i read like some
article or some paper about some new
technique for like rendering
grass or something and i'm like oh man i
need to try that and usually that's like
sometimes why i get nothing done for a
week
is because instead of fixing existing
problems i
add grass to the engine i did that a few
months ago i was like okay i want to try
this out um
so but but without that i think that
like one you know why in a way why not
do that because
um i think that that's that keeps the
passion there that that makes it fun
and i think that you need to look for
that as well whenever you're working on
something
yeah otherwise it's solid if you find
something really interesting which turns
you on
um it kind of brings uh
some of that juice back yeah yeah
um yeah cool so okay so yeah you
mentioned you started programming with
pascal
um have you have you had much experience
with languages
other than c plus plus in your kind of
modern
we'll say life um well
i had um with javascript
don't hit me
[Music]
and don't hit me again but i i
don't understand why people hate it some
people do
like i hate it a lot maybe it's
associated with some
scripting and not interesting stuff or
something like that
but it's kind of a pretty cool language
uh
to use especially if you know c or c
plus plus
it will be easy to understand yeah i did
some python
but not much it was just
i was just playing with python basically
uh what else well basic obviously
i remember i used to write um
macros for word i think was for
microsoft word in vba
and using its api i don't know
why why i did it i needed something
from word i wanted something
i wanted to do something which it
couldn't do and
yeah so i did that
and one of my jobs uh previously
which i had um it was related to
applications for testing and they
had uh javascript and
visual basic and later python
under the hood and you could use them to
write
testing code for ui
so that's where i also
tried some of that stuff interesting
um well i also did a little bit of
c-sharp
just a little bit yeah i don't don't
really like it
yeah i i really like c sharp c sharp's
probably my favorite language after c
plus plus
i i i don't like it
it's um well let's take javascript right
it's
it's like c plus plus but it's different
um
and sharp to me i guess it looks like c
plus plus
very close to c plus plus but something
is missing something is off
right maybe i just don't have much
experience with it
maybe that's why i have this opinion but
i'm not really a fan yeah i think like
i think in in university um i
yeah actually that's one thing i really
wanted to say as well is that because
you were talking about how university
didn't really teach you much and then
practically is where you learnt a lot
i'm
i'm the exact same i say this all the
time um
and and again like i i still haven't
really met anyone who was like oh man
i'm so happy with my university
programming education like they taught
me all the languages they taught me all
the stuff
and i know that universities like that
exist because every now and then i'll
run across like some github repository
that is like some course on graphics and
they're
they're actually like generating like
grass in vulcan using a tessellation
shader and i'm like where are these
courses
i was like doing gl begin gl end like
here's a
square um but anyway yeah i think that
like um
for me as well it like really my c plus
plus programming
like siri actually good i'll say
programming maybe
began like when i started working at ea
and the two years before that when i was
in university
um it was very much like uh i i mean i
like i wrote i wrote it i was coming
from java so there's like a lot of new
keywords and stuff everywhere for me
because i was like how do i make a new
object i'll heap allocate it because
that's the only way you do it in java
anyway
um so there was like a lot of stuff i
didn't understand about the language
um but it's like my my world completely
changed when i started working at ea
because
um the way that they wrote code was so
different to what i had been like
academically taught in university
um it was so like foreign almost
and it for some reason it just seemed so
much easier
to write code even though they were
doing more advanced things it there was
almost like a sense of freedom which is
interesting because i feel like in
university
it's almost like they had all these
rules that were like well you can't do
this you can't do that you can't do this
you know global variables are bad
this and that is bad and like you know
looking back at that yeah like those
that does make sense like yeah you
should not use global variables
everywhere
but you should never use global
variables like that's
there's a difference there you know um
and i think that
that's one thing that that working in a
real kind of
development environment because when i
started at ea i immediately
started on the game engine team it's
like an intern so i was still kind of
very
inexperienced but i was on the game
engine team um and this was not on
frostbite this was on a smaller engine
that they use for like the mobile games
um
and uh it was i was like the seventh
person to join that team and
um so because of that there was like
quite a lot of time that the technical
director spent with me and i think in
about two weeks he really straightened
out my
my c plus plus um and that just
again goes to show how much that
practical experience is worth because i
feel like
in two weeks there just because of being
exposed to it all day at work
um and actually working on something
serious being thrown into the deep end
like that i learned
more than in the entire two years of
university
um before i started that internship
which is uh yeah super interesting
yeah uh if you do something practical
especially on an existing code base it
teaches you
um it certainly taught me a lot of
tricks like i
wasn't that much of a fan of templates
when i started because
templates look look weird
you don't understand like from the
get-go what they do
uh i still think that uh certain
templates
are like regular expressions you know
you write it
it makes perfect sense but you look at
it in a month and it's like
what um
um yeah but uh my opinion kind of
changed on that
i saw their real application real world
for real tasks and
um now i'm a fan of templates
yeah i i think that the way i looked at
templates was
so different as well because i had come
from java um
and i guess university had not really
explained to me that
they are not like generics at all um
they're way more powerful and you can do
way more things than just being like hey
this is
this type you know it goes there um now
and
kind of like generics and then like
that's kind of it um
so yeah templates for
when i started when i learned the real
power of them it was completely
different and again didn't do that at
university
oh okay so i guess back on track
what we're talking about advice oh i was
talking about
auto remember yep that's right since we
are on the topic
i said you're a fan of order you were
saying except for bull
yeah yeah um so i guess auto
is like templates lite
version of them like a teeny version of
templates because
uh type inference rules are basically
the same
for auto and for template uh parameters
so yes a real world uh story
uh from our code base
now the way um our
theme works um it obviously
reads the code it builds a syntax stream
uh for that code and then
it uses that syntax tree to
run text and diagnostic rules
and there is a class named a walker
walker which basically goes
the tree recursively from top to bottom
and it visits every node basically it's
a visitor
uh it has virtual dispatch it
calls a virtual method from the
tree node itself and the three node in
turns calls visits something
well you see you know the visitor
a typical one and
it was rubbish its interface was
really garbage because those methods
which um do something with different
node types
they were all returning a pointer to
the base class of so the tree um
it's an it's a hierarchy it's also a
class
hierarchy for different expressions
statements and so on
uh and it bothered us a lot so we
decided to change that
so now it uses real types
not just the base class and auto help
there because
you write auto everywhere and then you
change you make a huge change
basically every method which is used
there
is changed everything
you can touch is kind of
upside down now but your code just works
so
yeah you don't have to
change anything uh in the parts of code
which use those methods
which take return values from them
yeah so it's a it's a good thing um
uh yeah auto just be careful about that
i guess because
it doesn't understand references yes
um oh it was what was that
um with triple a rule right
from uh josiah
doesn't matter a triple a rule almost
always
auto and now it's almost almost
always auto ampersand ampersand
yeah because that understands references
yeah like um auto is what it was
interesting because i'm always really
torn about
auto because i feel like um
yeah there are so many refactoring
situations as you were talking about
where it just makes life so much easier
but the fact that it's so easy to
refactor that code
in a way to me also is very dangerous
because
if it's so easy to make such a major
change and then your code just compiles
then it's almost like but what if i
accidentally do something
and i don't know like i still i
definitely don't use auto as much as you
do
um which is i it's very interesting that
you kept it for bull
um still don't really understand why i
don't know just bull
[Laughter]
just had to save someone someone there
um
but yeah like i think that mostly um i i
i try to use auto for longer types
and especially in it because in a lot of
cases it's very obvious
what the type of data is going to be
from like the name of the function
you're calling and it's returning a
value and
you know what it's going to be so in
those cases i i do like to use auto
um but in some cases and i feel like the
more i program the more i
start to use auto because i just i'm
just like well what's the point of
having all this
but there are so many situations in
which like for clarity i'll deliberately
write the type there i might i might
even change auto to be the type just
just because there might be like a time
when i'm reading that code
and i might have been like hang on a
minute what's what's being returned
there and then if i
if i realize that i'm having that
thought then i feel like
the code in a way has failed because i
can't just
i can't just you know i can't quickly
skim through it
and be aware of what it's doing
yeah and that's why it's important to
write it so it reads
like a sentence yeah
if you have if you have that type of
question like
what the heck does this function return
maybe
maybe it's a problem with the function
name
and not the way you get its result
it it might be well in some cases yeah
in some cases i would probably leave
types there's not
many of such situations in my practice
usually
usually auto works fine and it
well it's clear what it does yeah
especially with those things like you
know now
one cool feature about auto is when
if if you have like a vector in your
class encapsulated inside
and you want to return iterators you
just
declare two methods like auto begin
return vector begin auto end
and that's it you don't even have to use
um anything uh like
i i usually write usings for uh
types i use in classes so i use using
directives uh because it's
it's just easier to me uh to use
like internal types i guess uh which are
declared inside the class and something
from the outside
and i used to do like
using iterator blah blah blah
now if if i have to do something like
that i'll just write auto and
don't even bother
especially with modern compilers which
are very good at it
yeah they can optimize cold better i
believe
uh in some cases when you do that
yeah and but but that like as you were
saying the whole reference kind of
trapped that
that is yeah reference it's yeah i feel
like
but i think that like um because it
won't it won't automatically make
something a reference but it will
it will it will make like if something
returns a pointer it will
it will add the pointer obviously but
can you optionally also write auto
pointer or is that going to be a double
pointer now
no you can you can you can write auto
auto
star and it will be a pointer so yeah it
understands how it works
yeah oh default references
oh i was going to say that that that
always catches me off guard because
it's almost like okay well the asterisk
is optional
but the reference isn't because the
reference if you don't add it it's not
going to be a reference so that's
i feel like that's not the best design
you can you can actually remember
what's going on there quite easily
because
a pointer is well it's like a value type
if it makes sense so it's a it's an
address it's um
it's an end basically it's a value and
reference is
something weird you know it's
kind of the underlying value but it
kind of isn't yeah and auto
uses basically by default it takes
whatever you give it by copy
so it can take a pointer by copy but you
can't take a reference by copy yeah so
i think this this trick kind of worked
for me
it clicked at some point yep yeah that
makes sense
um yeah
um so yeah i think getting back to the
the programming thing
um so you know since
kind of have you noticed like a a big
difference
in um because it's interesting like i
see pvs studio i see working as pvs
a pbs studio it's such like as such a
meta kind of cpus thing right because
you're focusing on
actually programming it's almost like if
you were working
on like the cfos language itself like
you're focused on the
on the code right um you're focused on
analyzing code and trying to figure out
you know certain things that might help
developers have you noticed a big
kind of shift in um how you yourself
look at c plus plus code and how
you uh kind of see all of that i guess
since
since you've started working there
um i see undefined behavior everywhere
and not everywhere but um
if it happens i i will probably spot it
and i've become um
a lot more caution uh courses about
pointers really
okay because pointers are not your
friends even if they
pretend to be your friends uh
and that's because they have that uh
you know funny state called a null
pointer
and the compiler well no one will stop
you from
uh just calling a method from a null
pointer
and that's ub and that's bad really bad
because
uh if you're lucky you'll just crash
if you're not lucky and your compiler
decides that
okay looks like an undefined behavior
this pointer is probably know um and
as we know undefined behavior is
something which can't happen
really because it's forbidden
your program is ill-formed so it can go
and optimize it in some funny way and
you won't even notice problem
uh so well i'm not saying that pointers
are bad or anything because uh
i just became cautious of them and
usually
like um sometimes it happens when you
want to pass a pointer to a function
stuff like that i usually try to
do references instead of pointers if i
can
so i i will check it in the calling code
uh if it's valid and only then i will
reference it and push whatever is under
it to a function or
to a class or somewhere yeah so when
when you were saying when you were
saying like um about the whole undefined
behavior thing
what exactly about a null pointer is
like undefined because i didn't really
get that
um well about null pointers
uh nothing is undefined
it's a well-defined value no pointer is
a valid
value of an address well it's not a
valid address but
yeah easy but the referencing
yeah no point is undefined behavior yeah
yeah uh yeah so as as long as you don't
try to dereference it you're good but
as you try to do it um funny things uh
can happen
yeah so you're saying that like some
compilers will
i guess you know either constant fold or
like look at look at um
certain values of pointers and determine
that hey that's probably
a null pointer as you were saying and
that can happen
they can do that okay yeah and
you know uh this whole undefined
behavior thing
um this is what many compilers
build their optimizations upon so
if you want to optimize code uh you have
to prove
that certain things will happen certain
things won't happen
and stuff like that and undefined
behavior
gives them that you know that space
to maneuver more
and when they see
that something is probably um
unviable let's say some that some code
contains something that the compiler is
not counting on
happening in the code they can apply
different optimizations
and they can screw up in some cases
really
yeah okay that's interesting oh yeah
i know very little about how compilers
optimize code i just know that it's very
scary
it's that's a lot of math yeah i i
i'm not uh a compiler back-end guy
i'm not a cold-generation guru or
something
so it's it's kind of a mystery i just
know
general stuff about that yeah right so
so what what kind of stuff do you
do at pvs studio
um oh i'm doing
features and diagnostic rules
um oh the latest thing the most
interesting one was the type system
the new one because the old type system
was
really old and it um like it wasn't
uh going to work anymore it's still used
but
i will change it so i've developed this
new
uh type system thing uh to replace our
existing one
okay i don't know if if i should go into
details so just give you an
overview how it works um yeah like i'm
interested in
and yeah just like okay so yes so you
look at
c plus plus code and you want to know
basically obviously you want to know
types of
all variables and what functions return
and stuff like that and there are two
approaches to
this problem how do you how do you
know how do you store this information
in your
in the compiler in a static analyzer
anywhere
you can use uh encoding as a string
you see and um you see in asteroid risk
so
you write somewhere b i for example
pointer to int or you can
create a class hierarchy for your types
and store objects and maintain links
between them
so your end pointer becomes a pointer
which holds an int inside and you can
ask
what uh hey what type are you pointing
to and it will give you okay it's in
and we had this uh this whole
stream encoding thing and we are
running out of letters because
there are so many different things you
have to uh you have to
encode in c plus plus type system
that it will just it will bog you down
so what i did i i wrote this
uh hierarchical hierarchicals
i can i can english a hierarchical
system which will
replace the old one
so i borrowed it from clang really but
don't tell anyone okay not entirely but
parts of it the idea yeah i borrowed
that was interesting
yeah and usually i don't have a set
responsibility like you go do that and
that's it
yeah so i can do various things
right now i'm working on one diagnostic
rule
and then it will be another one and then
we'll see
how large is the development team at pbs
studio
well the entire team or just c plus plus
let's go with both okay so c plus plus
is 1 two
three four five six
seven people it's about seven people
um other teams are smaller and overall
it's about
like 30 something people i i think yeah
so that's it that's pretty big true
that's not kind of bad
yeah yes and we are based in one
city so we are not distributed yeah
in any way well that that's good because
um
yeah i'm not a huge fan of working
across different time zones i mean it
like it has its benefits because um you
know you can handle you can hand off
your work if if you're
if your team's all around the world in
different time zones you kind of hand
off your work at the end of the day and
then some other times
we'll pick it up in the morning it's
like a 24 24-hour day kind of
development cycle but that's also kind
of stressful because it's like well if i
don't finish my work now
no one's going to be able to do work the
next day in like china or something
so it has its ups and downs yeah
oh this lockdown situation we had in
working from home
uh it was awkward
because i'm i'm used to being able to
you know i
i need this guy how come here tell me
this tell me that
and when you're working from home
i guess in distributed teams also
you have this um to talk to someone you
have to
go write them you have to start a call
yeah you have to do a lot of unnecessary
things
so inconvenient
um at some point i i got used to it and
then
the lockdown kind of ended
oh man yeah it's um it's uh it's
interesting i
like i saw some of my friends some of my
friends from
from ea um which i like i haven't worked
today for almost two years now so
um but every now and then like i keep in
touch with some of my some of the people
that i worked with
and um a few people have literally
started working on the team a year ago
and they still have not seen the office
because about a year ago um
in australia and melbourne like the
whole lockdown situation started and
everyone was working from home and i
think now they're slowly returning to
the office but that's
so interesting because i feel like um
because i i guess i quit
about eight months or so before
like the lockdown started um and
obviously i had no idea
but like i would not have enjoyed
working from home because i
um in like i think 2016
i got chickenpox and i
had to stay home for like well a week i
had it
and then another week i couldn't really
go anywhere because i was still kind of
infectious
um and uh and so i had to
i couldn't go to work and so i worked
from home
and it may have been the fact that i had
chickenpox but i hated it so much
it's like working for yourself from home
i think is slightly different
because first of all um you can just not
work which is not ideal but
you can do it don't tell anyone um but
then also
uh i guess you're kind of working on
stuff that um
stuff that you think is kind of uh
potentially interesting to you you can
take it easy you can
you can be like more kind of uh all
like you can you can do various things
that you might be passionate about in
the period that
that you're sick for i guess um so it's
a little bit different anyway i think
we've
lost yuri's camera you're back
you're back lost you for a second yeah
um i lost everything here so how do i
even oh yeah yeah put it back online
did you still hear everything i was
saying uh
um for the most part yeah just a couple
of seconds
so uh when i lost connection or
something happened
um i missed a couple of seconds so yeah
about chickenpox and
working from home yeah i was basically
just saying that like um
it was it was a total nightmare that was
my big experience of actually
kind of being locked down or in a
quarantine but that was back in 2016
obviously before any of this covert
stuff so
um i did not enjoy that so i could not
imagine working for a year
like from home um which is what a bunch
of people have had to do like in
melbourne
um i like that's you know working from
home
for myself is hard enough but then like
for a company i feel like
you know when you used to have a team
because i people kind of i think people
are different people are different
socially you know some people like to
have their headphones on and
not talk to a single person during their
work day if they're in an office and
maybe type them a message i was not like
that i would get up and just annoy
people all the time so i think that
missing out on that potentially and as
you were saying it's a lot easier
to just be like hey man you know do you
know this do you know that come to my
desk whatever
um is a lot easier as you were saying if
you're not a distributed team with
like branches and in in other countries
or in other cities or whatever
um yeah i feel like like for me that
that's also like a big deal i think to
be like in an office together
i feel like for me personally that
that's a huge kind of productivity boost
well by the way uh i know some people
who really like to communicate in
in text and they're sitting like
next to each other oh yeah there's a
meter between
them and they type yeah and i'm like
come on you're sitting in a meter one
from another
and you are talking through some server
on the other end of the planet yep
probably just to just
say things like what
i i will never understand that no
neither do i
yeah i don't
oh yeah i i i um i
yeah it's it's a very interesting time
at the moment
um and and the thing is like i would
hope to say that those people who
who used to not talk to each other in
person when they were sitting next to
each other now regretting that they're
like i could have
i could have talked to a human at work
and now i can't anymore but they're
probably still happy they're probably
even happier
so i'm not going to say that uh i i
think they
they didn't notice that you can't even
know
um i can still type you a message yeah
whatever what changed
nothing changed things are good that's
funny
um
um so okay so so what do you think then
um
you know what is a definition of good
programmer
in your opinion like is is there certain
things maybe that have stood out to you
when looking at use cases or things that
pbs studio has detected where you're
like man
there seems to be a group of people
maybe that are writing this code
but that's bad why do they keep doing it
you know are there
are there metrics really to measure i
guess what like what's a good programmer
in general
well that's big
um that's a big question no it is a big
question
it's a very open-ended question and i
have no idea what the answer is
i think a good programmer is
someone whose code you can pick up and
continue working on it without too much
problems
so i i think that's
that can be a working definition for a
while
i i've seen bad
um like quote unquote bad programmers
um there are different types of people
who do that well who i can call bad
programmers in quotes um
and their code is always
scary or too fancy or just a mess
without any kind of any hint of
architecture or logic
so usually even if even if technically
it's good and it works
it can be a pain to read it so i i guess
being good is not about it's not about
being fancy
i think uh many people have this
misconception that
oh i'm writing this really great
complex code which looks weird like it's
from another planet i i can write in c
plus plus like uh
in functional style like in haskell or
whatever yeah
um well you can but
but think of someone who will uh
actually
work on your code after you so
what what will they say so i think
a good programmer yeah it's someone who
can write
it's a portable code let's say like that
and
there is also a second part of it is
when you know stuff like algorithms
and you can write efficient code
which works fast you can see things uh
uh possibilities for optimizations and
stuff like that
that's secondary uh that you can learn
uh but your culture of structuring your
code itself
and uh creating some meaningful
you know architecture and something
which is easy to understand
for other people i think that's the
primary thing the most important one
yeah no i i i have to agree with you i
don't i don't know
if i'm good okay don't worry about that
yeah i i used to be good
i used to i used to say that as well um
like the whole i don't know if i'm a
good programmer or not but then i
realized that like
uh i feel like i've said that so many
times and i don't think anyone yes
um but but yeah like regarding
regarding what you said um yeah i think
that
writing being able to write code in a
simple way is possibly
more beneficial than being able to
write some crazy template magic that
potentially you know generate some kind
of internal compiler errors on certain
compilers and
um no because the thing is like i have a
couple stories
um one of which is
uh basically when i was at ea
um and by the way ea is the only
programming job i've ever had so if i'm
like
at work or at ea then um you know i was
there for four and a half years and
that's like that's
outside of my own projects in university
that's it
so um in case uh anyone's like oh
back at ea it's like my my middle name
yes it's my only real job
um now now i'm not a real job person
anymore
um but uh we had this problem where i
literally could not compile some code
because someone had written like
this crazy template code that like
put data together from different types
and something to do with tuples i don't
really remember it too much
but it was it was big and um it took i
think the technical director of the team
um but and another technical director
and the senior software engineer who
wrote that code
uh half the day i think i want to say
like four hours
plus at my desk because i had discovered
this problem and i couldn't compile the
code
trying to you know dissect these
templates simplify them
see what goes where what does the
compiler output
what's happening with these types why is
it not compiling
um and uh you know i've been in
situations as well where there have
literally been like
compiler internal compiler errors from
certain templates or from certain things
and then like it's like okay well maybe
there's a bug in this version of
official studios compiling we need to
update it now we
went to try a different different
version or whatever and
um i think at that moment when i
realized i'm like why does this
why does this exist and i asked that i
asked that i was like
why why have you written because the
person who
wrote it was next to me why have you
written this code in this way like i get
that it's like
at a certain point it feels like you've
done this because
it's a game to you like
it's a game it's like how do i take
these templates
and how do i you know just pass this
through so many things so that we can
write the code like this
in one line and it does like a billion
things
and i think i realized at that time that
it's it's
it's not cool it's not worth it and it's
just a tremendous waste of time
yeah um and
i heard also a story about templates uh
but it was i i personally i wasn't
uh someone who dealt with it uh but
i heard about a guy who was a big fan of
templates and he just
used them everywhere and he managed to
create a monster which broke the
compiler
the compiler just couldn't chew it so
or it was a link ran out of memory or
something
yeah ran out of memory and crashed uh
properly
so yeah you can go overboard with it
it's pretty easy to you know to get
carried on
but in many cases they
really help yeah like um
when we needed a way to iterate
the tree our infamous industry
and stuff like that uh we needed a
convenient way to iterate it
and we decided to create an iterator
basically
which would go um
so we ended up having
four iterators
two of them are well
one of them just goes statement by
statement
um the second one goes uh
like it traverses lists
like when you have something uh comma
separated
and two more are basically the same but
they
also provide counters so you
dereference it uh it gives you a tree
node and
its number right and
all four um they basically
work in the same way it's basically the
same template
code with some compile time you know
magic
with if cons exper and things like that
and you just you just push them into a
special container
well container it's an aggregator object
for it
for your tree nodes and you just go
begin end or you just
push it into the four for loop
into a range based for loop and it just
works and and really
there's not much code if you look at the
code for
that thing there's not much but
it does really a lot of functions for
you and it
makes life easier it's not
too complex of course um when complexity
rises too high i think that's time to
stop with
this kind of thing with templates and
meta programming because you can spend
all day
you know making all those fancy things
like
uh recursive type inference mm-hmm
or things like that yeah very very
similar to macros
and how like sometimes you need to have
like variable arguments go
somewhere with the macros and i remember
trying to
write my assertion macros and learning
all about how we can
trick the trick the compiler to redirect
to other macros if there's like
this amount of arguments versus this
amount of arguments
oh that's a mess um but i think
i think there's a fine line um because
it's interesting that you say that like
because yeah like templates are great
i use templates all the time i love them
i think that you know some
game studios i think have just outright
banned templates
i mean i can understand that decision
but
it also would really mean that in
certain areas
there would be so much code duplication
um when it where a template can easily
generate all that code for you
and it's might the template function
might be like three lines of code you
know it might be so simple
they're like well why not use a template
here it's not like this huge thing that
you know goes through every latest c
plus plus feature and
you know it's not even it might be
really simple and i think in those cases
it's definitely like a no-brainer
but i think that sometimes um
you have to ask yourself is this feature
actually complicated and
you know difficult to understand or do i
just not understand it because um i feel
like you know i might
in the past i might have been like oh i
don't want to use templates at all like
they're scary whatever or anyone who
uses temp i've seen people say this on
my discord server
i've seen people say certain things like
this c plus plus feature is bad
because no one understands it but in
reality
that person doesn't understand it
because he's known about it for two days
um and then like i feel like there's
there's a lot of kind of
you know there's a lot of that sense in
in a lot of programmers that like
you know well i know everything this is
stupid
you know that's dumb i don't understand
this it's it's clearly too complicated
so
there's that line you know and and i i
don't know maybe some of some of the
stuff that i'm saying these days
i might look back on in five years and
be like really
i didn't use this i just didn't
understand it back then
yeah i i used to think that um
c plus plus is becoming overbloated
you know it's it's becoming too huge we
don't need
all that stuff uh like
see with glasses like
strawstroup made it
um it's perfect and things like that but
then i realized that okay so
you get a feature it's not
mandatory you are free to ignore it if
you don't like it
but um if there is a feature
there is probably a reason why it exists
in the language yeah so maybe before
discarding it
go check it out go look at it and then
maybe you will love it
so there was that moment when
my opinion that really changed and now
um i used to be scared of all those new
standards and
whoa what are you bringing into my c
plus plus ah
why now i'm kind of well okay
if it's not worth using i won't use it
if it's
if it's great i will adopt it and
it will be like of great help
of great use
yeah so i was going to say that
like yeah i don't i i
don't understand all the people who hate
siblings plus because
it's so bloated apparently like yeah i
get there's a lot of stuff that's
coming in like i get it you know maybe i
wouldn't make those same decisions but
whatever is going and it's going in
i have always just used what i've wanted
to use i don't understand why people uh
get so upset about certain things being
in c plus plus you don't need to
literally use every feature in the
language
um you can just use a subset of them and
i think that ultimately that's the way
that sql plus is intended to be used
if you are using every single feature i
think you're
do you're doing it wrong like i don't
think you should be using everything
you know if you're using every single
feature
i think i don't know maybe you're
at the university and you have exactly a
lot of assignments about
every feature in the world i don't know
uh in production code
even if you're in your bad projects
i i don't even know what subset of the
language
people typically use but i would say
it's no more than
30 percent of something
well maybe more yeah i mean
the library it will be less because
standard library is huge and
yeah stuff there of course yeah a lot of
stuff
the stuff that i have never used in 10
years or whatever but i think that
the key there was what you said about
about production code
is it production code because i think
that that definitely
needs to be treated differently from
maybe some kind of
like oh you know i have never used this
evil sea plus feature before
i'm going to try and use i'm going to
try and write like a little game that
revolves around it
just for my github or whatever because
um you know when i was talking about
templates earlier there is this kind of
um
uh meta programming kind of template
tetris
uh thing on github that i saw a while
ago which is basically like
it's tetris but every move uh
the program needs to get recompiled
because the templates are what generate
the like console output of where the
pieces are on the board so when you make
your move or when time passes and the
piece is falling
your c plus plus code has to get
recompiled because that's all kind of
it's the actual processing happens at
compile time for the
for all of the tetra stuff so that's
that's
cool that's exactly that's right that is
really
like you would never write any code like
that probably in a production
environment right
but it's a really cool little repository
um
so it's not that i hate that stuff it's
just that if you're actually affecting
people's time and and you know
doing things are necessarily complicated
then that's bad and going back to what
you said about
um the fact that a good programmer is
someone who can write that code
in like a really nice i guess and simple
and clean way
um yeah i i like i totally agree and
that's
something that i have learned to
appreciate a lot more
since working on hazel on my game engine
um
you know with so limited resources you
know i've learned the fact that
um i i need to write code in a simple
way
because if it's complicated you know
someone from the community is going to
rock up and be like hey can i help out
with something
and i'm like sure man well it's probably
going to take you a day to get a build
going um because i'm using you know xyz
build system that you've probably never
heard of and it's cutting edge and
you have to download this version of
visual studio because i'm using the
experimental sleepless plus 20 features
and i'm doing you know and this and that
and then at the end
like it's cool to see the fact that
there's there's
four people um at the moment who uh
have uh are actively working on on hazel
with me
um just from the community you know just
contributing
and i love the fact that they've just
told me so much that like hey man it's
really easy to pick up this engine and
just start writing code for it
um because that was one of my goals
because i realized that even for myself
you know i'm not going to be able to
handle this if i run into a template
error that takes a day out of my very
precious development time that i have
whilst also running a youtube channel
and you know doing a lot of other stuff
that aren't
directly related to full-time
programming on hazel
so i think that yeah for sure kind of
working
um working on your programming to get it
to a point where
it is clean it is as simple as possible
anyone can read it and
understand it that is a skill that you
should also focus on
not just like oh how how cryptic can i
make my code which i think appealed to
me when i was a teenager
i was like i want to write my my code in
a way that no one can read it
because then that will impress like my
teacher or whatever because he won't
understand it
that's rubbish if your code should make
sense
um yes i used to um
well back to my pascal days um
i used to put a lot of things in one
line i thought it was cool
for some reason i don't know now i don't
even
i now i don't even declare two variables
in the same line
well maybe there are exceptions but i
typically i don't do that
i declare variables each in its own line
because that's just
it just makes sense it makes more sense
i think then
yeah doing that comma separated
initializer thing
oh yeah not initializer declaration yeah
[Music]
okay so and yeah about cryptic code
believe it or not i saw lambdas
which were calling lambdas inside them
um yeah and
they were declaring and calling other
lamps
so it was
yes and optional my favorite example is
optional of optional of
variant on some types
um i saw that thing also
oh man i had i had such a big rant
on a live stream about a month ago
because someone had accepted a pull
request
um into like the game engine series
version of my hazel engine
um which is like a tutorial series
version so it's not like my code base
but still i'm protective of it
um where they had accepted a pull
request that was like it
changed it basically added um i think if
you try and open a file
and it returns a path to as a string
as just a standard string um and they
had changed it so that if you hit cancel
therefore nothing would be returned so
it would return an
optional of a city string and i was like
i had a huge rant about this because i
was like do you
do what what strings can be empty i was
deliberately being like you know if
you know if string empty or if path
empty then clearly it's been cancelled
or whatever that the actual object
itself
has the state why are you wrapping it in
an optional and then having to go
through all of that code
um so like that i think that's a good
example of like
because the thing is i know i know about
optional
i had i made a video a year ago on my
channel discussing optional
like i am aware of its existence but why
would i use it if there's literally
not only can strings be empty it's not
like i'm doing some weird thing like
checking the memory address and being
like is the size exactly one bite or
whatever because they're not terminated
character or is there nothing there or
am i doing something crazy
there's a function called dot empty like
it's
there you know you don't even have to do
dot size and whatever
it's this dot empty it's a container it
can be empty
you know why are you complicating things
by being like oh let's
let's use this you know library feature
that is going to also be like thousands
of
of extra lines of code that you're
including through the header file and
and uh some overhead also because it
uses
additional memory yeah things like that
yeah uh well
i guess it can make sense because in
your case
uh this empty or not empty stream
is kind of a binary logic so it's
similar to true or false so it's if it's
not
empty it's kind of implies true and you
can use it if it's empty
implies false but if you want to signal
like
three states and not just two you can
use
against optionals or something like that
of course so
if it's either empty or not
empty or there's no string at all so
yeah maybe
yeah dislodge because of course it is
possible for
zero or empty to be a valid state that
might require a different response than
if the data was not present
at at all um so yeah it's not it's not
that i'm saying optional is bad i'm just
saying that um
in that case that was a huge
complication to the code because not
only does it
you know wrap string and optional and
complicate that whole thing
and add additional includes and all that
stuff it also means that when you use it
it's it's a different api as well to try
and use it and you have to
do like the i think use the d reference
operator to get the
get the data out of the optional and do
all of that stuff
you know what what would have been
funny if they used with that optional
after uh it has this method called value
or
to give you a value or some placeholder
value
i used that and gave an empty stream
there
and then you can check that beautiful
yeah there's so many i think that
there's so many features
that again don't need to necessarily
exist um which which is like
have you felt like personally that there
are usually either useless features or
that the c plus plus because like i mean
i've mentioned that like i don't think
that is getting bloated to the because i
i can just choose what i use right in
the super
c plus library but are there like
working in pvs studio i imagine that
it's not up to you to use those features
or not
because you're going to be proofreading
essentially
people's code which will use those
features so
how like have there been a lot of
situations in which you've seen new sith
plus you know standards come out and
then you're like i can't believe we have
to support this garbage
well it happens all the time
when a new feature comes out because
especially when concepts were announced
and
they were described at cpp reference
and in different places already so we
knew
concepts are coming and there was a
point when we
started using was it
it was visual studio 29
and it was some specific version of it
so it used to be a time when you
include anything from the standard
library
and you have the latest cpus plus
standard
enabled in your visual studio and you
check that file
and you crash because of concepts
they started to integrate them into the
standard library
and we started crashing and supporting
that
yeah they look um
kind of alien uh you don't expect to
see that in your well i expect it now
but back then they were kind of alien
looking and supporting it yeah it was
it wasn't really pleasant
so to speak but it ended up well so
it's fine no we don't crash on concepts
anymore that's good
that's a plus yeah but
i i don't think there are
like features which
should not exist um
i said before i think that they probably
exist for a reason
so if you don't if you don't know the
reason behind them well
just don't use them yeah so that's
simple
yeah no definitely like i think that no
except std um any
that's pure evil as i heard yeah
because it it does some crazy stuff uh
under the hood with dynamic allocations
and
things like that so yeah it's kind of
i think it's just a badly designed class
it's not
like evil you know of itself but
yeah so any is
yeah i would i would streams
yes i have streams they are really slow
okay
well yeah that's not that's not
something that shouldn't exist
that's just something which could have
been better
yeah so like o stream so do you mean
like
if stream and of stream and that kind of
stuff
everything from uh inherited basically
from the
basic i o stream or whatever the base
class is called for for all of them
or basic uh yeah yeah so it's it's c out
uh it's uh yeah file streams
of they have some kind of
synchronizations uh in them and
this makes them slow and inefficient
right
i personally like for output um i like
the
fmt library okay it's awesome
yeah it also like formats your strings
and stuff
yeah yeah it's a modern printf
yeah basically and it's it's
great so it can use files and
the console and yeah anything and it has
compile time
uh uh calculations built in
so you can form your formatted strings
at compile time
okay yeah even yep
yeah that that's good that sounds
efficient
um yeah i was going to say something
about
i think either about five sorry i
distracted that no no it's okay it's
okay
um yeah don't don't the kind
don't fast don't the okay because i'm
always like i feel like i've been using
just the c style file api and focus and
um you know all that stuff forever but i
think recently i was like okay fine i'll
do the sql source version
um doesn't doesn't it just wrap the c
style
file api as far as i'm aware what does
it you're saying it adds up like
synchronization
stuff you mean the streams yeah um
just specifically like of stream or if
stream
um well they wrap things up somewhat but
there is um an additional layer to them
so yeah they can be inefficient but
again if you are just reading a file
like if you're not doing a thousand
input output operations
per second or whatever well it doesn't
really
bother you when when you start uh you
know putting a lot of things
uh in the console uh you may notice
a slowdown because that's
not that can be really noticeable
um especially if you're doing if you're
trying to do it fast
yeah not like one message a second but
a thousand in a millisecond or something
so in loop
it will be it will be slower than printf
and printf i think it will be slower
than
fmt i think it's the most efficient one
but i
may be wrong here not sure
what about just native like windows api
console
outputting stuff windows api
um um don't really know
about a native api
in terms of performance i kind of assume
that that's probably what printf is
calling anyway right it would have to
yes most likely or they both call the
same thing
yeah like let's say like i i used to use
the windows
api a lot more in the past because i
think
um only in like c plus 17 i might be
wrong on this but i think only in like
simple
17 they finally introduced that
amazing like file system api then now
yeah i think that was simple 17. um no
and like
again i i say amazing i i don't really
care i i haven't really inspected the
performance or anything like that
um but from an api standpoint it's it's
great because
um for example you can list the files in
a directory you can create
nested folders um instead of just one um
and then having to do that like there's
all these kind of usability things that
in the past it was was like well i want
to list the files in a directory
i have to use the windows api um which
you know i mean there are still certain
things i'm still not sure i haven't done
this lately but i'm not sure for example
you can memory map a file
using the c plus plus kind of cross
platform api or if you need like the
win32 api
for that but um
those things have gotten better though
in c plus plus which which i'm
i for one i'm grateful for but but then
again it's c plus plus so i don't know
what their fascination with
operator overloading is but the whole
way that like now if you want to
concatenate like file system paths using
the fastest name api you just
use the forward slash like divided by
operator
to just add paths together and i'm like
i thought that was a joke when i saw
that like on
some code but i don't know they just
love their operators
maybe it's like oh look i'm
i'm typing a path well no no it makes
sense
it makes sense but it's just a little
odd to see that like in the code i guess
um it's quite funny though i think yeah
it's
like uh i i saw
the guy who was that was the chili maybe
chilies
um i don't know if if you watched him
or do you know who chili's chili tomato
noodle uh different seen a few of his
videos
um yeah he's funny in his awesome
and um one of his videos
he shows the vector like arithmetic
vector
and he he goes like okay so we have
addition it's plus
okay the subtraction is minus um
that and that and cross product hmm
which operator would i use oh percent it
looks like a little cross makes sense
so yeah it
operators you can go crazy with them
yeah there was you can easily go crazy
with them
uh there was some
i don't remember what this was
unfortunately i don't know maybe this
was a boost
thing but there was like some
serialization library
and i think they used the ampersand well
wasn't it it was like
it's like a bit wise and the bit wise
and i guess operator because it's not
like a reference thing in between two
things to
put objects into a stream or whatever
yeah i think they also use
uh some other operator maybe in
this pipe thing yeah um
well and again uh streams uh input
streams they use the
left shift and right shift to you know
right and read but that makes sense
really
because you are left shifting something
into a c out
probably you want to push it pushing it
you're pushing it into the
that's how i see it but that was
interesting because
um when that was one of the weird things
when i was coming from java
into cbos plus obviously the first thing
you learn about is how do i print
hello world to the console and it's like
oh
and then i was like because i was doing
like software rendering
algorithms and stuff in java so i was
very much aware of like the bit
operators
and i was like why why is is this what
is this
how how is this bit shift left like i
literally spent like
hours i think being like is this some
kind of weird mathematical thing that
i'm not getting
like how is the string
being bit shifted into the output stream
oh that was good times ah that's that's
so cryptic that that's that's the thing
like you
s c plus plus hello world and you're
already like
what is happening with with this why
can't i just do
system.out.printline or
console.writeline in c sharp it's so
simple
and then c plus plus is like well you
need to you know shift this left into
this place
yeah it it can be it can be difficult
when you see it for the first time it
will put you off guard
right yeah that's that's i feel like
that's almost a fair introduction into
simplest class and just how flexible and
crazy it is
yeah no wonders no wonder some people
are like um
i saw on my discord the other day
someone was
saying that like c plus is bad i'm
tempted like
every day to rewrite my entire engine in
c99
um you know and then people were like oh
what like really white c
plus you don't you you want to rewrite
your whole engine c like
why what's so bad about c plus plus i
don't know it's terrible i hate it
you know and there's like it's it's
interesting because it it
um i mean i you know segwaying from what
we were talking about about the terrible
hello world example like sure but
apart from that i just feel like there's
so much negativity
around programmers and i don't understa
like
there's this culture of just hatred
towards everything
there's like there's superiority there's
like i know everything there's i hate
everything
like how have you come across like that
kind of culture a lot like
what's your experience with this what do
you think about that uh that's a common
thing
from my experience um it's it's
almost a good you know
[Music]
it's almost a part of the
good behavior to hate on some other
language or
whatever oh you know those web
developers are stupid or
those i don't know those c
plus plus dudes are masochists you know
you have to manage your
memory um all the time
yeah yeah yeah so
c plus plus developers are masochists
how do you use that you have to manage
your memory it
always it always leak in memory
come on dude unique pointers for you
you don't have to do anything really
yeah oh it's
i don't know maybe it's uh just our
thing
maybe that's what we do like you um
you crawl up in your little um cozy
niche
and then you look outside and that's bad
that's bad
that's stupid that i hate um so
i don't even pay it uh i i don't even
pay attention to that anymore so yeah no
everyone has everyone seems to have
really strong opinions
um and i feel like uh i don't know i
feel like
when i see that these days maybe i've
just grown up a bit more but i just
i feel like i um value
like respecting people a lot more to be
like okay
if you want to do that like that's cool
you know
like you're allowed to do something
different
um so yeah i mean
again maybe i'm in a position where i'm
just looking at my youtube comments all
day and then people are just being liked
well i can't believe you did this i used
to lie i used to watch your videos
um and now now you've done this or
whatever
um well there's just like yeah people on
again
i've got like well almost 20 000 people
in my discord server and so the amount
of hatred
that i see there sometimes it's like my
moderators are just outright banning
some people for being toxic
because because of the whole
disagreement thing
it's kind of a shame oh well
i guess that's inevitable because
you just cannot make everyone be
respectful and civil and stuff like yeah
that's that has always been that will
always be
so i just we just deal with it and
move on yeah i don't think it's
i really don't think it's that huge of a
deal
as like all this
you know hate and stuff like that
because
if you're on the internet you can just i
don't know close the chat below and
or ban them or unsubscribe
or something yeah if you come across
someone really
toxic and uh you just ignore them
yeah basically that's what i do anyway
yeah no it's good advice um you have to
just
just uh find find a group of people who
are actually respectful i think
um instead of just being put off like
programming or whatever forever in fact
you know
just anyone out there who's watching
this if you need someone to talk to
about programming who's not gonna
just hate you then just send me a
message i'll try my best
because that's one thing that's one
thing i am passionate about like is
um and one thing i really hate is is
all the hate and hate plus hate is like
two negatives right
it's a positive i think you
you have to multiply them yeah positive
from the next
exactly multiply the hatred
by by the hatred yeah eight multiplied
by hate equals what love
yeah love plus hate plus hate not hate
hate times hate equals love
yeah perfect we solved it um
yeah what were we talking about before
that i think i was saying
the whole discord thing and c99 and
people hating
all the features oh yes c99 uh
new features um
yeah i think it was just mostly about um
my point with that i think was just
mostly about
how um a lot of people do like to hate
on c
plus plus and and think that you know
we need a new language or you know we
need rust or we need jonathan blows new
gi or whatever programming language to
write games and
i refuse to write a game until that
language is out because that's the
reason why my game isn't working
or like you know all this other stuff
like what what do you think about
like is c plus plus really that bad that
we
that we are you looking forward to a
replacement like what do you think about
that
um well if i thought
that c plus plus was bad i wouldn't
have been here so okay um
yeah no i really don't think it's
bad and i don't think that
any replacement is really necessary
um if
people get put off by the
difficulty of the language uh well
you can use a simpler subset um and
you won't see any all of that complexity
will go unnoticed
basically in many cases um
people some people are still afraid of
that
you know memory leakage too difficult
to write gold you have to manage
everything yourself thing
which is also not true anymore with
the new standard library features all
new so
i think the language is becoming more
like it it's becoming safer to use
on the one hand and on the other hand
uh believe it or not i think it's
becoming more beginner friendly
just to make it
completely beginner friendly
you probably need to enter it
from a certain angle and use
like some small subset of features
because
uh if you try to understand the entirety
of the
standard library or templates uh or
anything complicated uh
when you are a beginner you will fail
obviously yeah but
yeah if you if you just something small
uh throw in some scl there like unique
pointers uh
to prevent your memory from leaking and
to prevent you from complaining about
oh my goodness i forgot to free that
memory block
um i think you'll be good um
even if you you are not a c plus plus
guru or something like that
yeah so yeah i i think it's a in some
sense it
it's even better uh becoming easier to
use
uh and easier to learn
in some sense yeah
small areas yeah no i definitely like
i agree with that and i think that one
thing that separates um
a lot about the languages is their
libraries right like c
sharp for example i've really liked c
sharp because their library is so good
like the library's huge um it's very
kind of similar to java i think but
you know in my opinion city shop's a lot
better than java but um
that might be controversial for some
people um
[Laughter]
um but i think that like some like c
plus plus library in the past like as i
as i kind of brought up that example
earlier with the with the file system
api how you can't even list the files in
a directory before c
17 as far as i'm aware um you know it's
getting better
like you can now right um but i think
that a common misconception
um is that c plus like people look at c
plus plus as the same kind of language
as
java or c sharp or you know something
else and then they're like oh well
what do you mean like there's no build
system or what do you mean there's no
that thing
and my kind of opinion and my the way i
look at it
is that um c plus is supposed to be
fairly bare bones like
if you want to build system you have the
flexibility to decide
what build system you use or you can
write your own build system
you know that's not something the
language offers but that like and again
they're going to change that potentially
but um that's not something the language
offers
because it's it's flexible you know you
can do what you like but if you expect
it to be
this kind of language that you can
easily write you know
all of this code in in a matter of hours
and everything builds nicely and
everything it does automatically it does
everything automatically for you i think
that's
i think that's not gonna happen and
that's definitely a bad way
um to look at it uh because it's kind of
it's a low-level language yeah uh
in the end of the day it's not an
assembler
assembly assembler um
it's higher level kind of than
c which is an assembler with
a human readable syntax yeah
yeah i mean yeah exactly kind of like
that
uh so but but still it's a low level
language
yeah uh it's not something like it's not
something
you will use for your um
high level stuff like four uh if you
need a quick and dirty
ui application for something if you need
a website if you need
i don't know um some
quick um solution for some data
processing
or anything like that uh you won't
probably use it
uh but if you have the foundation
which allows you to do certain things
easier
you can still use it for even those
tasks
yeah well uh if we get
the network um library
in std that would be great yeah
that's yeah that's still something i
think that's missing that's
present in javascript yeah
they have a technical specification for
networking
so maybe it will get into a future
standard
yeah that would be good we are
definitely getting modules
yeah which will be like
like java packages and things yeah well
not exactly but
it will be similar yeah it will become
easier
to get dependencies for your application
yeah i hope that works out well because
i'm a bit skeptical but we'll see
well well usually
if you read descriptions and articles
from people who are involved in making
this kind of stuff or to have let's say
early access to
features um they are usually optimistic
so
yeah we'll see when it releases we'll
see
yeah yeah i mean there's there's it's
interesting there's so many features but
i feel like there's so many things like
you were saying about networking there's
other so many things that are missing
still um but uh
you know to to kind of reiterate what
you were saying earlier as well
regarding the fact that if you are a
beginner learning c plus plus you
shouldn't be using all the features and
and trying to trying to look at um
what's interesting about class plus i
think is that
it's so and that's one of the things
that i love about it is that it's so
kind of um it's so it's so free it's so
flexible you know you can
write c plus plus code really however
you like and you can use this you can
use that
you don't have to use you don't even
have to use like object-oriented
programming or classes or
you know uh methods or inheritance yeah
you can go see style with it yeah you
can do you can do anything you want
really right um
and uh that's so cool to me because i
feel like it can morph into whatever my
programming style is and usually it's
it's a blend of the of of a lot of
styles like i don't want to be stuck in
in object oriented programming mode um
because that's very limiting in some
cases and not very
uh performance friendly we'll say in
certain cases
but then i also don't want to be without
that
because i like that sometimes and it
makes sense so
i think it's really cool for that but it
also means that if you are a beginner
learning
c plus you can look at two code
repositories and they won't look like
the same language
um and that can be that can kind of be
difficult as well i think
um yeah especially
when people um overuse those modern
features like
templates lambdas well templates are not
modern but
let's say it's it's kind of stylish
yeah uh yeah
really you can look at two different
code bases and you will see
absolutely different tricks they use
here and there and the architecture will
be different
somewhere it will be a lot of template
classes on template classes in template
classes
somewhere you might have i don't know
three functions and
lumped us everywhere or something so
yeah
it can become crazy yeah
but um but as you were saying as well i
think
um there are so many useful things there
that definitely should be almost
standard when you're beginning and you
mentioned unique pointer
um yeah like that that's a really good
example of one and one thing i tell
some of my students as well is tr like
you know well okay
maybe you don't understand what it means
because first of all like unique pointer
is a
weird name i think um i would probably
call like scoped pointer or something
but
like um it might not be something that
you understand
um for certain you know if you're a
beginner but try and write your own
unique pointer it's very easy um you
know and it teaches you a lot about
stack allocated objects in c plus plus
and and how
you know you can use the constructor and
destructor to your advantage in a scope
because especially if you're coming from
java with a garbage collector
um and you allocate an object in using
the new keyword in java in a scope well
that's great that doesn't teach you much
um but in c
plus it's very very different and i
think that that's that's a really
useful lesson and not to mention as well
there are so many
like unique unique pointer like fine um
you know
you don't really like you don't need to
use unique points
i would i would highly recommend
everyone does um but you don't need to
use it you can just delete something
at the end of at the end of the scope
manually like you can do that right
it's just automating it for you but
there are other things
that you can't really live without and
like a good example i think is shed
pointer
like having a reference counting system
right because
in certain situations you don't know
who's still holding on to an object and
you don't know when you can delete it
you know like a really good example i
think for um all the game engine
programmers out there is
what if you have like kind of a render
command cure or a render thread
right like how do i know if that if
i might be done with my texture on one
thread or on one kind of
area in my code but there might be other
things that are still dependent on it
for example maybe the frame that needs
to render with that texture data
hasn't been rendered yet how do i how do
i know when i can delete my texture from
memory or from my gpu memory
like that's a really good example of
like well if you use like a shared point
i mean we don't use shared pointers and
hazel
um we have like our own reference
counting system but um that concept of
doing that and sharepoint provides you
with that in this hip as well standard
library
means that you can actually physically
do things that you couldn't
like you can't just manually delete
something because you don't know who
still owns it
so there's so much useful stuff there
definitely that even as a beginner i
think
um those tools are kind of there and
that's
to me the spirit of c plus you know they
provide you with a language but there's
so much stuff you can build on top of it
to make things easier it's almost like
um
minecraft i don't know why i'm comparing
to that the box of
legos i don't know
i was gonna say like mine minecraft and
you can you know you can chop down a
tree and build a wooden pickaxe and then
you can
you know use that to get stone and then
build a stone pickaxe and
you kind of just you you you build you
could you you're supposed to in my
opinion build tools
on top of c plus to help you write code
um and i think the library does a decent
job
that's that's true yeah
um i i saw someone in chat was saying um
do you have any career advice
career advice so like like if someone
wants to get a job
as a class plus programmer i assume like
what what
how would you recommend they go about
that
well how i went about that myself
this i can tell you i'm not an
experienced
experienced dude i just well
i i i talked about it and
at the beginning um i just caught it
uh for like for fun
and then um my
job uh i was having at that time
it kind of warped me i burnt out and
i decided to find a new one and i looked
uh looked up what was available and i'm
like
um static analyzer c plus plus that's
interesting that's what i like
let me try it and to my surprise i
passed the interview kind of easily
because
um i had experience at that point
i'm not like you know
i think i'm not the guy to whom you
would go
for career advice really
because i'm not i'm not that experienced
in
you know this all this stuff
yeah i mean how would they learn uh i'm
sorry
i would say learn learn algorithms at
least basic
and data structures because that's the
big one
everyone wants to know about and don't
be afraid to
code on on paper yeah even
right that's
that will help on the interview because
um
that's common stuff people will ask you
in many cases to write something without
a compiler
and without a computer yeah
um i actually used to really enjoy those
uh when i was in university we had
certain exams and we had to write code
on paper and everyone hated them
but i um i really liked them and
i i think it's interesting like there's
a little story that i think i've told
before
um certainly not on this podcast because
this is episode one but
um i've when i was learning programming
when i
when i started learning programming i
was about 16 and
i was a really interested as i mentioned
in like software rendering and like
you know ray casting kind of algorithms
and stuff to generate like a doom style
game
just in software um and i was so
interested in that that
i printed the code um i printed the code
onto paper this was java code
and i took it with me because we had
like a school camp
um and so we went away basically for
like five days we went camping
um with like my friends from school but
this was like actually like school had
put up had put on this camp in schools
in australia like it's very common to
basically every year starting from like
year four or something when you're 10
years old
you go camping like every year basically
and you learn like survival skills and i
guess australia's you know
you need to be able to like you need to
be able to like survive
but um no it's really fun and i'm really
glad that that we do that but um
so i was in the school camp in year 11 i
was 16 and i had
i had this display display folder for
display this sounds ridiculous display
folder of like java code
of like rendering and stuff and i just
started learning i was maybe like two
months in
so this was two months of me programming
like at all i had not written this code
i was looking at someone else's project
i had printed it and i was um basically
at night at the school camp with a
flashlight
i was you know with a torch i was
looking at the code and i was reading it
i was trying to understand it because i
couldn't really
um because i had barely started
programming and here's this huge thing
um but the point is like i i i don't
know i was
so passionate about it and maybe because
of that
i was um totally okay with then
writing that code on paper because the
other thing that i would do
and again i don't know why again i was i
guess i was a teenager no one i had
no one to mentor me i was learning
completely on my own
my teachers in high school my it
teachers in high school
actually one of them um my it teacher
told me uh when he caught me looking at
java code in class
and in it in high school they didn't
teach us programming they taught us like
a little bit of php maybe a little bit
of web programming but a lot of it was
just
databases and microsoft access i think
just
rubbish really um and so he told me
that i should stop looking at
programming in class because it's never
gone
it's never going to amount to anything
so um
unfortunately i never saw him again um
after i quit high school because i would
love to go back and be like
actually i think my programming has
amounted to something but anyway
um the point being that i was uh i had
no one to mentor me because no one in
high school
knew programming apparently weird um i
don't know how but um so so i one thing
i would do i would do very often is
i would kind of learn to to create this
little engine in java that could render
and rasterize pixels
and i would literally come home from
school
and start a new project almost i feel
like
every night i don't know how probably
not every night but i did this i feel
like for months
i would start the project from scratch
and i would try and write as much code
as i could off the top of my head
without using any resources
um and again it's a bit weird because
it's like well wouldn't it be better to
just progress the project and the answer
is yeah probably
but for some reason it really appealed
to me that i could put on some cool
music in the background
and just write code and make stuff
happen from my mind
um i guess and maybe that's why when the
exams rolled around in university
years later i was like well okay i can
write code on paper
um and i still maintain that if you sat
me down in a room
i could probably write a decent
opengl renderer definitely not vulcan
definitely not but i could write a
decent opengl renderer
from scratch on paper and it sure
i'm sure there'll be syntax errors or
compilers and certain
things here and there but mostly i could
do it because
i don't know like i just feel like that
was kind of ingrained in me so yeah
programming on um you know did
what you were saying writing code on
paper for interviews learning
data structures and various algorithms
um
i think that's really useful as well if
you're trying to get a job because it
will teach you
a lot about the language and it
it it can potentially be an incredible
platform for learning more about
optimization and how the language works
as well
um because i still remember how
the technical director from ea was
helping me with a university assignment
um and he was my boss and
uh basically we had to write this like
breadth first search algorithm
we had to compare it to an a star search
algorithm
and then be like see this is why a star
is faster
um but he uh had
sat down at my desk one day and he was
like all right what's this rubbish
assignment you're doing let's blow this
out of the water
and he had basically written it in such
a way and
that there were no heap allocations
and that it was all just perfectly on
the cpu cache which i didn't know what
that meant
back then but it was just perfect and
it was so fast it was it went down from
half a second to four milliseconds i
think
it was so fast that they tried my
teacher
almost failed me because he was like
this isn't working properly
because it was faster than the a star
because just brute for
brute forcing brute forcing all of that
data
which was perfectly on the cache with no
allocations
was faster than doing all of the
operations you needed to do and all the
mathematical things
to actually figure out the shortest path
and
and all that stuff so my point with that
being that
you know there's there's a lot of stuff
you can do with data structures and like
with algorithms
and there's a lot of you know you that
it's almost like you know those youtube
videos it's like um
you know baking a cake you know from
beginner to expert or
five different what you know five ways
like explaining um
explaining quantum computers uh in five
levels of difficulty or whatever yeah
and it's like he's explaining it to like
a
child someone like a teenager in high
school university student
a phd student or whatever and it's like
different levels i feel like
with c plus plus like you can take a an
algorithm
or like you know something like breadth
first search and you can write it 10
different ways
um potentially and like you can just
you know use that as a platform to learn
more about optimization learn more about
memory layout learn more about like
why allocations are bad and and certain
other things
um so yeah definitely i think good
advice there
just don't um just
i don't know if uh i think it was
inspiring what he just said uh i really
do
uh just a warning to
people who might be over inspired
a little bit um you can
yeah you can um
you can do a lot of things and squeeze a
lot of
optimizations by using certain tricks
uh like cpu by using cpu efficiently and
so on but
in the general case um
you shouldn't use a less efficient
algorithm just because it's more cpu
friendly
or stuff like that because after some
point
uh the algorithm efficiency beats
optimization
if uh if you know what i mean so there
are situations when
for example you can do a bubble sort on
a really small data set and it will be
perfect it will be
fast as you won't believe
uh but you give it a larger data set
and all all of the sudden it will fail
yeah because of that
big o notation and um
the um the rate
of growing um
[Music]
yeah the time complexes yes it doesn't
scale well
yeah yeah so because of that
a certain algorithms uh will fail you no
matter how optimized they are so
yeah first um search
i think yeah i i think there wasn't a
huge graph right no i mean it was like
maybe it was up to a thousand
different yeah a thousand nodes or
something but um you know
for sure of course if you try and scale
that up it's gonna it's gonna be very
apparent that a star is a lot better
but um uh i guess the point the point
was to learn about those limitations and
also
again you know i think challenging
yourself to
optimize breadth first search instead of
just because you know you can implement
it
just as a beginner one way and it can
work but then
potentially taking that further
and learning a little bit more about
like oh so
so that's how memory works so this is
fast or this is slow and maybe i should
try and
actually care about how my memory is
laid out or
you know all of that stuff like another
actually really good example
i mean this isn't really like an
algorithm it's very simple but um
one one thing that i learned very
quickly when i was doing like software
rasterizing stuff in java
was the order of my nested for loops
because
um i noticed that in a lot of the code i
looked at the outer loop was always like
four
int y equals zero y is less than height
y plus plus to like fill a buffer
and then the inner one was fought in x
equals zero and i was like hi wonder
because that reads like you know y first
and then x and i'm like well wouldn't x
y make more sense and
i still wrote it like you know i didn't
write x in the outer loop i wrote y in
the outer loop and everything was fine
but then one day i tried it the other
way around and it was like half the
performance and then
i think at that moment i learned that
well yeah if i'm writing a value into a
buffer
you know skipping the entire you know
kind of going down the column instead of
going across the rows
then i'm getting like a cash miss every
time i write the next value in and
that that i think is a really powerful
example of um
how kind of trying to optimize i guess
certain algorithms
because the result is the same it's the
performance that's different
um learning how to optimize certain
things in that regard can actually teach
you a lot about
how the language actually works um and
how computers work and i think
um simple specifically does a really
good job about teaching you how
computers work
yeah yes you can say that i think
um if you if you don't care about your
well it's not well no memory layout is
also important it's more how cpu works
that's what you should be concerned
about here
and contiguous data is always better
than anything else
that's why that's why sd vector is
always the best choice right
yeah no like i'm not always but but yeah
you should prefer vector like list
and then use something else if vector
doesn't
really help you yeah vector and like
unordered map
i think are probably my top two most
used things
i use map sometimes like usually when i
want a sorted
data set so like a good example is um
recently
uh material sorting for like um you know
certain
certain materials you might want to
render they physically need to be
rendered after so if you have a
transparent material like glass you need
to render that after you render opaque
materials
otherwise there'll be nothing to see
through um into so like
you can use like you know some sometimes
i put
materials into maps that are sorted
because then that way you can you've got
a sorted map
so map map is also sometimes used but
unordered map i think is just
you know great obviously it's a hash map
and then vector and then yeah like a lot
of people ask me okay but what about the
other data structures and like what are
the data structures
um because like i feel like 99
of my use cases um usually at least in
the type of programming i'm doing
um falls into unordered map and and
way way more commonly than that the most
common is vector
and yeah they'll be like unordered set
and stuff sometimes but like
mostly that kind of stuff um
yeah contiguous memory definitely
important and also
you know order one i guess lookups
for the hash kind of stuff is also very
powerful
um another map
i think it has a catch there
if it runs into collisions
you may end up running
quadratic time rebuilding the entire
underlying structure but
still it's so good that
okay yeah once in a while maybe
one operation will screw you over
but yeah it's okay we'll forgive we'll
forgive it
we'll give it because it's good um
someone from chat i asked why std vector
is better than std list do you want to
answer that
ah sure that's because the vector
stores its data in a single memory
buffer
inside so it's a contiguous area of
memory
and to address it is very efficient
because
data is located um
like uh one value after
another so cpus have
a much easier time working with that
if you use a list every item
in the list is somewhere on the heap
and nobody guarantees you that they are
located
anywhere near each other so every time
you read
an item from a list you you are
addressing somewhere
into the memory and your cpu goes
work to work really hard at that point
because
its cache is invalidated
because you are touching some cold data
somewhere in the memory
so that's why a vector is more efficient
yeah i think that um a nice little
example
that i had about that um this isn't to
do with vectors directly but
what you said about cold memory um
meaning
memory that hasn't been like memory that
hasn't been recently accessed and that
isn't
part of the the memory that the cpu may
have fetched
um one other thing that i was shown
as well at a point was that um
sometimes it's faster to recalculate
data
than it is to cache it and retrieve it
so um
i had a situation i think in my sparky
game engine which was a
game engine i wrote like six years ago
um where i was calculating i think
offsets for a string
or i was doing certain font metrics or
doing whatever and so there were a lot
of like
additions and subtractions those kind of
operators
um basic math operators add subtraction
or whatever
um and i had the idea at one point i was
like okay well that's dumb i'll just
add these two numbers together and i'll
cage the results somewhere
and then uh um i discovered that
well actually it was slower to retrieve
that cached data than it was to simply
add the numbers again
first of all adding numbers is
ridiculously fast it's
it's not but a cold memory read and
that's
what what i think is really important
for people to understand
accessing memory also has a cost and a
sign
and potentially a very significant cost
um
but adding two numbers together usually
um you know that's significantly cheaper
than having to fetch memory which you
actually didn't already have nearby in a
in a decent cache so um
i think yeah that's that's something
that that definitely um and
that's again as yuri said that's why
vectors are good because the memory is
especially especially when you are doing
uh when you're doing calculations
using some values on your stack because
the stack
is it it has a huge chances to be a hot
area so you are always
doing something with the current stack
and the cpu will
will have much easier time right in
there the only drawback of the vector is
that
if if you reach the maximum
capacity and you add a new value it will
reallocate the entire buffer
yeah but
vector is also smart so it won't uh
give you like the number of elements
plus one it will give you like twice as
much after the reallocation so it's
it's not a huge deal or you can use
reserve
yeah and reserve resize um
both very good and yeah i think i think
the
from memory the at least the msvc kind
of uh implementation
vector will allocate 50 more i think
memory so if you have like 12 elements
you add one more it'll
do like 18 or something um so yeah it
will reallocate a bunch more and you can
i think control that as well if you want
to pass in an allocator
but anyway um uh that's something i was
gonna say about
uh vector oh yeah and then also um yeah
so there's two costs there's the whole
as you mentioned reallocating the buffer
but then there's the okay well i need to
get my data from the old buffer into the
new buffer
and so it's it's yeah i think it used to
be just
copying that data i think at some point
maybe before move semantics i don't even
know how that used to work
but now obviously now obviously it will
try and move it
um if possible if you're if you've
written a custom class
with a proper move constructor and
everything it will try and move it which
could potentially be a lot cheaper than
i guess in the past it used to
like if you had like for example a
vector of strings did it really used to
it just copied i guess it would have to
copy everything which
yeah it could be a disaster it would be
yeah it would copy everything and
allocate their internal storage
as well yeah so now yeah now you're just
stealing underlying resources
and placing it somewhere else so it's
move semantics uh
is one of the examples of great
improvements
yeah for sure i agree i think i think um
and now looking back on on
c-plus plus i feel like it was a scary
world before move semantics because i
feel like
there's so many cases in which um it
just speeds up
your code um yeah
because you don't yeah you need to copy
oh and now we have um
uh one more wonderful addition is copy
illusion
and uh return value optimization
which are wonderful you can return
objects by value from functions and
not be afraid of any cost basically
because
in some cases your compiler will be able
to
do it at literally zero cost
by just constructing the object right
there at the call site
yeah um and i think like
though that's actually one of the
reasons why yeah for return value
optimization
um definitely that's it's really
valuable um but then also i really like
using
um and place back like with vectors i
feel like i do that so often
i'll just and a lot of the time i'll do
it with no arguments i'll just do
like vector dot in place back and then
i'll assign
that result to like a reference um you
know so i'll have like object reference
blah blah equals that and then i can
like it might be a struct it might be
like just a struct
and then i'll fill that like with data
or whatever um
and uh like you know it's not really
construction in place
but um it it
i i think last time i checked at least
it's a it's
and this is one of those things with
siblings i think that sometimes
you think you might be doing the right
thing but you might not be because
i feel like there are some i remember
profiling this and there are some
situations in which
um copying memory um seems to be faster
than
referencing it um like
i i i remember we and again i don't
remember the details of this and this is
why i always tell people this
um you need to test stuff
like anything we say on this podcast
first of all
um could change compilers become smarter
you know c plus adds so many crazy
things in 10 years i feel like
it'll be even weirder um like stuff can
change obviously but also
um it depends what environment you're
running on it depends what compiler
depends what platform it depends what
cpu architecture so many things
are kind of up in the air here but i
remember a few years ago
um one of the things we had was uh we
had like a matrix
uh like a mat four so four by four
matrix um 64 bytes
and we were passing it by const
reference and we discovered that if we
did it was at us maybe there were a
bunch of them flowing into the function
or something but
if we changed it to be by value it
seemed to perform faster
yeah you can give some insight on that
oh yeah because referencing something
by address is again going somewhere
in the memory and it depends on the
actually on the size of your object
um i think on x
64-bit architectures if
you have like an object um
of about four pointers in size
about four pointers i think so meaning
uh eight eight uh what is it 64 bytes
of 32 bytes yeah um
if you pass it to a function by value uh
it will go directly through
cpu registers and it will be faster
than reference in yeah yeah
for relatively small objects passing
them by
value is better than referencing them
yeah
that's why well i
started doing that a while ago
if i have an object
like yeah maybe three four pointers in
size
i just push it everywhere by value
unless i have to modify it
whenever whatever i give it uh but
yeah if you just need to read it uh you
can safely
use by value uh
data passing yeah yeah oh and my video
is
is so slow for for some reason it's like
a little laggy it's okay it's not too
bad though
um i was gonna say that uh yeah and
obviously it also depends if the object
is
if it's just destructive data then
that's fine but obviously if it has like
heap allocated memory backing it and
copying it with us you know
re actually have a copy constructor that
does something like allocate memory in
the heap
then yes um that would be bad but other
than that if it's just
kind of a pod data type i guess plain
old data then it's um
yeah then sometimes it is a lot better
to pass it by value
which is interesting um and again one of
those things that i feel like i
i learned recently
okay and i i really think we got a
memory leak in discord
because really what's your memory uh
um i really think uh i've ran into a
memory leak
in discord or something because it's
yeah it's crawling for me right now
yeah what's this what's the memory usage
does it say ah i don't know
maybe it's the laptop here
let me check it mine seems pretty okay
i updated mine before this podcast just
uh
yeah my mine is fresh
freshly installed let me
do that just for just a second sort of
yeah no worries
maybe something else is uh this is a
good time by the way if anyone in chat
is uh has any questions um
then maybe uh this would be a good time
um i'll write chat now and i'll see it's
one of the benefits of having the
the podcast live um
yeah it helps you kind of deal with
deal with unexpected situations i think
someone earlier asked um
uh well like uh
should you always prefer to use um
standard array instead of vector and i
think that um
uh like the the the difference between
the the uh like std array and sc vector
is just that sd array is kind of like a
a normal kind of c style array like it
it allocates memory on the stack like
you just created it's a stack allocated
blob of memory um which obviously is an
array of x amount of elements that you
also have to declare at compile time
because it's all stack allocated
um uh whereas vector overseas is heap
allocated so i guess like
the first answer to that is um it
depends if you need the array to grow or
not
that's usually the answer they teach you
in university if you need a growable
array a dynamic array then use vector if
you need a static array use
a cd array but the the much deeper i
think answer to that question
is um you it's also very valuable to
know
where the memory is coming from so stack
versus heap sometimes
it's easier to be like okay well i have
a i have an array
it could be like i have a bunch of
values that could be three
there could be five of them there could
be ten of them i guess i'll use a vector
but in reality maybe you should just
allocate an array of your maximum size
like 10 and then just use that because
if it's on the stack
it's going to be faster um so
well let's try to adjust my headphones
it always fell off
but um yeah my point being that uh
that's a good example i think of it it
helps to understand
the behind the scenes of like what's
actually happening rather than just like
one of them is resizable
one of them is not so yes you should
prefer scd array if possible but it also
um uh your camera is disappeared it
it also um it's just broke again
yeah okay i switched to my camera
um yeah it it uh it um
it also very much depends on things like
uh lifetime you know
do you need this to exist uh you know
outside of the scope
in which you're allocating it um do you
need
uh you know how big is it gonna be
because you don't want to wind up with
like a
stack overflow exception there's a
there's a lot of um
there's a lot of kind of considerations
there but mostly it's just that yes if
you can you should use
a city array because the memory is
better
better memory uh by the way can you see
me now
yep i do everyone sees something weird
is going on here i think it's the it's
not discord it's the laptop
doing weird stuff yeah
we're coming up on two and a half hours
now so uh yeah
probably a decent time to start wrapping
it up i don't know how you're doing on
time i was meaning to ask you before
this podcast started how much time you
had available
um but i i guess i forgot that's okay
no don't worry yeah um
uh it's not like i have to do something
urgent because
everyone knows that i'll i'm in the
office by the way
everyone knows that um i'm going
on this podcast so yeah it's sanctioned
so it's not
it's not really a big deal except it's
4 p.m right here so
um maybe we actually should start
cracking
i'll stop we'll start wrapping it up i
was going to say you're you're here
doing the podcast everyone knows that
and meanwhile everyone else because
you're in your private room
everyone else in the office is just
sitting at their desks watching the
podcast
um i don't know maybe
we'll figure it out because they very
um they very much could do that yeah
um i was gonna also i was gonna also ask
you if there's um
because you mentioned obviously about
like personal projects and stuff so is
there anything you're working on
outside of uh your job that's like
really interesting that you maybe like
to share
um i used to do that then
i went all perfectionist and i
privated uh my github repositories uh
in hopes to you know make them
uh looking better yeah um
so currently it's like you know
it's like hidden so because i'm
i really um i have this
kind of a perfectionism sometimes
um sometimes i'm overly critical of what
i'm doing so
if i see like oh i don't like this
uh this is garbage this is wrong yeah i
need to
redo it uh i may
like you know hide it under a rug and
then put it back
when it's redone so right now my github
is in
um a sorry state yeah so i don't i don't
think uh
it's worth looking at i think
all it has is a c make um
template kind of which i made uh to
like you know to take it and use it yeah
right projects because
yeah but more so what kind of stuff were
you working on
i guess or all like do you have anything
in interesting like
just okay i'm not necessarily sharing
i'm excited about ai and stuff like that
okay mostly not not true
yeah so i well true i
is exciting but it's out of my league i
think
well so yeah i had experiments in that
mm-hmm i had autonomous autonomous
agents uh working running the cockroach
thing i mentioned
then i had well still have
um um
the game engineer kind of thing
which has um what i did there
i had an input system with
controllers and keyboard and mouse and
stuff like that i had events
for input and not only for input i had
rendering
i i think i could uh just
the point where i got to was just load a
model
in an obj file and display it and rotate
it in different
ways yeah and
also it had some options custom options
uh system which parsed um
some kind of configuration files
um i'm planning to return to it
uh well but not not right now not
not currently yeah
yeah cool cockroach especially i wanted
to
um make a planner behavior planner
oh yeah right yeah the cockroach stuff
definitely
sounded interesting especially when you
contrasted that with space invaders
it's like yeah that is basically and
then i did cockroach
cockroaches that sounds interesting
um cool all right well um yeah i guess
we'll wrap it up there
there are a few other questions um that
i don't know if they're worth answering
or not you know how i feel about your
guys questions usually the rubbish love
you all um
someone's saying that uh do you think
opengl is a good place to start with
learning 3d graphics um
my personal opinion is yes i think that
i talked actually talked about this in a
video recently on my channel as well
that i think that um opengl is uh
because the api itself is
kind of simple and it abstracts away a
lot of the driver
kind of stuff that you need to actually
do you can focus more on
the actual code to render interesting
things
rather than like low-level stuff like
synchronization and memory and and
stuff like that so i think that um if
you're after learning
about graphics programming opengl is
going to be a lot of an e it's going to
be a much easier time for you and you're
going to
actually be able to spend more time uh
working with the graphics have you done
much graphics programming outside like
the engine stuff you're working on
uh you mean me yeah
um i was um
like i wasn't diving into apis
really i used that um
you know windows thing again gdi uh
drawing on
on a window uh at that's because
i wanted to get a feel for architecture
first and then
write uh different renderers so yeah i
decided
just to use something simple uh first
well it was simple but of course it's
difficult to persuade it to
do something really good so
yeah maybe that was a mistake maybe i
should have started with
opengl or directx or something
yeah i um directx is also a decent
startup
dirt x11 specifically i think um directx
12 is very similar to falcon
but directx 11 is uh is is is um a
little bit
lower level than opengl but it's uh the
api is very nice and
it the validation is good microsoft's
tools are
brilliant um definitely better than the
opengl tools so um
that's a that's a good start as well but
again you know like you'll quickly
realize
um if you start doing that kind of stuff
that it's it's not
doesn't really depend on the api too
much um it's more about
you know how you're processing the data
what you're doing in your shaders you
know
how are you doing all that stuff so so
yeah
um okay cool
well thank you yuri for um jumping on
the podcast first episode
hope everyone watching uh enjoyed it uh
if you
you know i'll try i'm not exactly
because this is the first episode i'm
not exactly sure where this will end up
it'll definitely be uploaded to my
youtube channel
but then past that i'll try and you know
it'll be like available as an rss feed
and everything
um so you can probably get it on your
favorite podcast app and uh
and all of that stuff um and yeah in a
couple days it should appear on youtube
but
uh do you have any anything else you'd
like to say yuri
i'd like to say that uh it's not my
first podcast
and i would say it went it went
very well that's great so i i think you
did great here
thank you i'm i'm glad you enjoyed
yourself um i had fun as well
hopefully everyone in yeah people in
chat is saying
um thank you for coming on and uh
yeah hopefully there'll be a lot more
channel podcasts in the future um as i
mentioned in the beginning as well
uh it this this podcast was sponsored
and is sponsored actually by pvs studio
which is where yuri works as well
there's a link over here so
pbs-studio.com pbs
underscore churno for those of you
listening who have to type that out
but um if it's on youtube there will be
a link in the description to some
resources as well
pbs studio as i mentioned is a static
analyzer um
and uh you know run it through your grab
a free trial
hashtag churno or hashturno in the
message field we'll get you a 30 day
trial i believe
um for free and you'll be able to run it
through your own code and see what it
spits out it's usually going to be
pretty interesting i think for people to
run it
but um yeah i hope you guys enjoyed the
podcast thank you yuri once again
and i'll see you guys next time goodbye
bye everyone it doesn't quite work for a
[Music]
podcast
you